The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
It's 11:05.
OK, let's get started.
Last day we talked about
protein structure.
We talked about composition,
which is the primary structure
of proteins, and that's the
instant R group sequence, as
you go down the backbone.
The secondary structure proteins
is all about packing,
and we saw that there were three
different structures,
the alpha helix, the
beta pleated sheet,
and the random coil.
And the gambit here is to
maximize hydrogen bonding.
And why you choose alpha, beta,
or random coil depends
upon the instant R group
sequence, which is why in some
instances, you can't
form the coil.
Because the R groups
won't allow it.
And then lastly, we talked about
tertiary structure, and
that's conformation, and that
talks about our group
interactions, and ultimately
explains protein folding.
Today I want to talk about
denaturing of proteins, which
is disruption of secondary
and tertiary structures.
But before we do so, I
wanted to show you.
I found another movie reference
to chemistry.
This comes from 1957,
and the movie
is called Silk Stockings.
It's based on an old
Cole Porter play.
And this stars Cyd Charisse
and Fred Astaire, who were
both fantastic dancers.
And I want you to see
in this film clip
how she carries herself.
And she actually sings this.
She didn't have somebody
dub it over.
So the singing is OK.
It's not great, but you've
got to see her posture.
She's so graceful.
And Fred Astaire is a terrific
dancer, but he doesn't dance
in this sequence.
And last thing you need to
know here is, this is set
during the Cold War.
So she's playing Ninotchka
Yoschenka, a good Ukrainian
name, and she's a Soviet
representative.
And she's fighting with
Fred Astaire, who
is an American agent.
And they're talking about the
differences between the Soviet
and the American systems. So
that's the background.
It's 1957.
I guess we better get
some volume up here
so we can hear it.
And she will explain to you--
and remember, just
parenthetically, that my
particular interest in
chemistry is, of course,
electrochemistry, which is the
highest form of chemistry.
Now she'll explain it to you.
[BEGIN FILM PLAYBACK]
-If you studied, Kamachev,
you would know what
I am talking about.
-Who's Kamachev?
-He was one of our greatest
scientists.
He has proved beyond any
question that physical
attraction is purely
electrochemical.
-You don't say.
-Kamachev has proven it!
-For 30 years, he worked.
-I happen to have worked on the
same subject for about the
same amount of time, and I have
very good reasons for
believing otherwise.
-Facts are facts
[SINGING]
-When the electromagnetic
of the he-male meets the
electromagnetic of the female,
if right away, she should say,
this is the male, it's a
chemical reaction, that's all.
And though you Fascists may
answer with kisses, the same
applies when your Mr. And Mrs.
Hey-diddle-diddle with
middle-class kisses, it's a
chemical reaction, that's all.
Say in love, with you, I fall.
And in love, with me,
you also fall.
Though the uninstructed faction
calls it mutual
attraction, it's a chemical
reaction, that's all.
[END SINGING]
-You don't believe
in Kamachev?
-No, ma'am.
[END FILM PLAYBACK]
PROFESSOR: See the posture?
It's just unbelievable.
Fantastic.
OK.
So let's talk about denaturing
of proteins.
So we want to talk about how
we can alter the structure.
And we do so by invasive
means.
So let's get to the
next slide.
So here's the tertiary
structure, and I
can point to that.
The first thing I wanted to draw
attention to, is we can
disrupt that structure by
change in temperature.
So temperature is the first
agent that we can use in
disrupting, or denaturing,
protein.
And the whole idea here
is to break bonds.
But we're only going to break
secondary or tertiary bonds.
We're not going to do anything
to the backbone.
And a good example is what
happens when we fry an egg.
The egg has protein in it.
One of them is ovalbumin.
It's about 90% water,
about 10% protein.
And its native state, its
natural state, conformation is
a tight ball.
And the diameter of that ball is
small enough that uncooked
egg is transparent
to visible light.
Egg white is transparent to
visible light in its natural
form, but when we heat beyond
the denaturing temperature,
that changes the bonds in
here, and it unpacks.
And when it unpacks,
two things happen.
First of all, the length scale
changes to be great enough
that it scatters light.
So now the egg white
appears white.
And secondly, those various
chains entangle, and that
gives it its rubbery
character.
So all of that is happening as
a result of the increase in
temperature.
So second way that we can
operate, is to change pH.
And what that does, is it
changes hydrogen bonding and
electrostatic interactions.
Now I draw your attention
to zone two here.
In zone two, imagine if we take
that proverbial drink of
cola, and now the pH in here
goes way, way down.
You can see this N has got a
hydrogen bond over to here.
Now, if there's a proton excess,
the proton can cap,
because this is a proton
attachment site.
If the proton caps this
carboxyl, then this hydrogen
bond is broken, and now
this thing can unfurl.
Over here, you see, this is an
electrostatic attraction.
Again, the carboxyl could be
kept by a proton, and now the
plus minus electrostatic
attraction is lost. So by
change of pH, we could denature
what we see here.
So there's a good example.
And in fact, I think
we do this.
We pickle our foods.
And then this one I have,
because of my interest in high
temperature electrochemical
processing of metals, I've
been to Norway many times.
And this is a food that they
will never let me eat, because
they're afraid if I ever
taste this, I'll
never return to Norway.
But this is lutefisk, which
literally means lye fish.
And lye has high pH.
And this is an example of
denaturing protein by going to
very, very high pH.
And then you soak it and draw
back out and so on.
So there's a good
example of food.
Now the third one I want to
talk about is oxidizing
reducing agents to denature
proteins.
And what they do, they can
either create or destroy the
sulfide linkages, the
sulfur-sulfur linkages.
So for example, you see at
position number one.
Position number one, we
can use oxidizing
and reducing agents.
And a good example, that
comes from hair.
So first of all, I want
to talk to you.
Hair is protein.
And this first example is just,
how protein can, one
strand can bond to the other
by hydrogen bonding.
So up here you have one strand
and a second strand, and there
are hydrogen bonds
in your hair.
Now, what you do when you want
to change your hair by blow
drying is first you
wet the hair.
And the water goes in and
interrupts these hydrogen
bonds between strands.
So now each of these cross-links
that want to form
instead terminate with
a water molecule.
And now with the water
molecules, now you can move
the hair one strand versus the
other, hold it in place, blow
dry, get rid of the water, and
form new hydrogen bonds.
So what, on the basis of what
I've just told you, how can
you account for a
bad hair day?
What is a bad hair day?
A bad hair day is a day in
which it's rather humid.
And so water can get in from the
atmosphere and interrupt
these bonds, and then the hair
will relax, and go back to a
native state that is unfavorable
vis-a-vis what you
tried to achieve with the blow
dryer in the mirror.
So you want to combat this.
So what do you do?
Well, you bring out
covalent bonds.
So here's two strains of hair,
and there are disulfide
linkages between the
strands of hair.
So now with a reducing agent,
reducing agent is going to be
a proton donor.
And can you see, these disulfide
linkages are capped
with hydrogen, and now
they're terminated.
And so now the two strands of
hair are free to move relative
to one another.
And now when you're at the
beauty parlor or the
hairdresser, now you can take
this hair, for example, and
wrap it around--
what do you call this thing?
It's a mandrel in the
metallurgical word.
What do you call this thing?
Curling iron or something?
Yeah.
OK.
So here you are.
You wrap this around--
I know what it does.
I don't know the terms,
all right.
So now you see, we've got the
hair now wrapped around in
this fashion, and now we
use an oxidizing agent.
The oxidizing agent
is peroxide here.
You know the derogatory
term, peroxide blonde.
There it is, right here.
So the peroxide goes
in, and now it
removes these hydrogens.
The peroxide takes the hydrogens
away and reforms the
disulfide linkages, but
now the hair is
in this curled state.
You know, you might
have the opposite.
Maybe in your native state, your
hair, because of the way
the R groups are formed along
the length of your hair, you
know, it's always, the ones with
the curly hair want the
straight hair, the ones with
the straight hair want the
curly hair.
And so, you know, maybe you
could be running this sequence
in reverse.
But in this case, somebody
obviously wants curly hair.
Now they form the disulfide
linkages.
So this is the object,
here, of denaturing.
So now when we go over to here,
we have a disulfide
linkage, which is forcing
this run of the random
coil to stay straight.
But if we get, in this case, the
oxidizing, the reducing,
and what will happen is that
we will break this.
So the reducing agents will
destroy disulfide linkages,
and the oxidizing agents will
create disulfide linkages, and
thereby we can distort the
natural form of the protein.
And here's a fourth example.
There are many others, but I'll
just give you four here.
In the fourth one, we
can use detergents.
And last day, I showed
you the example of
how to do your laundry.
And so you've got this long
aliphatic tail and the
hydrophobic head, and you can
imagine if you take such
species and you've got this
hydrophobic pocket, the
species will operate in such a
way as to pull these non-polar
entities out, and
then destabilize
this hydrophobic pocket.
So depending on what the nature
is of the protein,
these various chemical and
thermal actions can lead to
denaturing.
So this destabilizes hydrophobic
pockets.
All right.
So that's pretty good.
Well, I think this is where I
want to leave it with the
treatment of proteins.
And I want to move on to
a second biomolecule,
and that's the lipid.
We'll say a few words
about lipids.
Lipids are not classified
on the basis of their
composition, but rather
by their properties.
So they are defined
their properties,
which is kind of unusual.
Normally we define things in
terms of their chemical
compositions.
And in particular, they're
soluble in
solvents of low polarity.
Some of the books say nonpolar
solvents, but even something
that's polar but only mildly so
will work, in solvents of
low polarity.
So that's the example.
They're insoluble in water,
they're oily to the touch.
And this includes things
like fats, oils,
these are all lipids.
Cholesterol, hormones.
These are all members
of the lipid class.
And so let's look at
some examples.
We've got some slides.
So if you start over here with
the glycerol, this is a
trialcohol.
And you can see the OH.
We're going to drop the H's, and
we're going to put these
long aliphatic chains on.
There's 14 carbons here,
plus the two, so
it's 16 carbons long.
And this also is seven
plus seven, and
then the two carbons.
And the difference here is that
in this case, it's all
straight chain.
In this case, we go for seven,
then we put in a double bond.
And by doing so, when we get
to the double bond, that
forces everything to go into
planar 120 degree arrangement.
So you go for seven however
you want, and then there's
this rigid 120 degree placement,
and then you go for
seven however you want.
Well, clearly, the one in the
middle is going to pack better
than the one on the left.
And so even though they have
seemingly the same chemical
composition, the one in
the middle is a solid.
It's a fat.
The one on the right is a
liquid, because it doesn't
pack well enough.
The bonds aren't
strong enough.
So these are both examples.
And this is called
a palmitic acid.
And you can see here
oxygen acting as a
bridge, as an ester.
So oxygen, over and over again,
acting in this way to
give us the ability to make
these other longer structures.
Now we can replace that oxygen
bridge with a dibridge.
So instead of having just an
oxygen here, we're going to
put a phosphate.
So with the phosphate, we've got
a phosphodiester linkage.
There's one ester, there's
a second ester.
And why we doing this?
Because nature wants to
get the spacing right.
And remember what I just said,
because by the end, you're
going to see that spacing
is everything.
So we can use this, and we can
even lose that oxygen, and put
something else here.
So here's a--
I'm not expecting you to
know these by heart.
I would give you the structure
and tell you what it is, tell
you its name, and then we
can go on from here.
So what do you see here?
Well, this is called
a phosphatide.
And this one is a
phosphatidylethanolamine,
because there's the
amine here.
And look at this thing.
Well, you've got a
phosphate in the
center that's the bridge.
This is the glycerol,
the three carbons.
In its most primitive
form, we could just
have hydroxyls here.
This is the fatty acid
off the one end.
Long chains here,
not to scale.
So these things should be
way, way over to here.
And over here, we have
an ethanol amine.
But look more closely.
Well, this is a hydrophilic
head, this is
twin hydrophobic tails.
Look, this is just
hydrocarbon.
It's not soluble in water.
So now you've got this
amphipathic molecule.
It looks like a detergent,
doesn't it?
This long, hydrophobic tail
could stab the grease, and
this hydrophilic head can
bond to the water.
And now if we shake things up,
we'll release the grease
that's binding the soil
to your T-shirt.
Got the phosphate bridge here,
and look even more closely.
There's a minus, and
there's a plus!
This is zitterionic, on top
of everything else.
So this can function as
a zwitterion, too.
And everything we learned about
zwitterionic chemistry
and buffering, this
thing can do.
That's cool.
All right.
So now I want to show what
happens when I take a whole
bunch of those.
All right?
So let's go back.
I want to keep this one up, and
I want to want to do is
take a whole bunch of those,
and show how lipids can
actually operate in order
to build complex
structures for us.
So what I'm going to
do, is I want to
represent that molecule.
So here's the hydrophilic
head.
That's the amine, right?
And then we've got twin
hydrophobic tails.
And that's your carbon
sp3 chains.
And I don't want to write
that so much.
So I'm just going to simplify
that as simply hydrophilic
head and hydrophobic
twin tails.
So this now represents
the twin tails.
Now if I put a whole bunch
of these in water,
what's going to happen?
First of all, this
is hydrophilic.
And what if I were to just
pour this into a beaker?
What do you think would happen
if I introduced this into a
beaker of water?
Well, this is hydrophobic,
this is hydrophilic.
Can you imagine that they
would all sort of
line up like this?
We're trying to stick
the hydrophobic
tails up into the air.
Because they don't want
to be down in here.
This is hydrophobic.
Doesn't want to be here.
So now suppose I put a whole
bunch of these in water.
More than four, right?
With only four, that's
the best can do.
What if I put some molar?
So then what it does, is
it forms a pocket.
It's going to do this.
All the heads are going to find
each other, and all of
the tails are going to
find each other.
Because now they're going to
form a hydrophobic pocket.
So they'll do it this way,
because they can-- can you see
how the heads can sort of make
a wall against the water?
And you go on and on and on, not
to scale, and then finally
you have some end
effects here.
So what have I formed here?
I've got something, first of
all, I've got a lipid layer
here, and a lipid layer here.
So together, I have
a lipid bilayer.
In here, there's a pocket.
And now, what I can do with
this whole thing, is I can
build a cell wall with this.
I've got a cell wall.
I've got an outside
and an inside.
So what happens is, when we put
all these things together,
because of the clustering
of the hydrophobic and
hydrophilic, we say this thing
is endowed with the property
of self-assembly.
Very hot topic in material
science.
And that leads to cellular
structure, and I think we've
got a nice cartoon here.
So this is taken from
one of the readings.
So you can see this with
the plurality of these.
They're actually showing
the twin tails.
Now, this was taken
from another text.
I like this one, because it
shows the hydrophilic top,
hydrophilic bottom, and the
hydrophobic interior.
And then this thing is called
an integral protein.
Why?
Because it's integrated
into the cell wall.
And let's think about this
protein for a second.
What must be the nature of the
R groups in this vicinity of
the protein, that it
sits where it does?
The R groups around here must
be dominantly hydrophilic,
otherwise it would get dumped
out of that zone.
And in here, it must be
dominantly hydrophobic, so
that it feels at home with all
of these hydrophobic tails.
And over here, it must
be hydrophilic.
Now imagine what happens.
I'm going to go back to that
drink of Coca Cola.
Forgive me, no brand names.
Cola.
And now the this zone here gets
flooded with protons,
because the pH is dropping.
So that could cause
conformational changes,
because pH changes the
conformation of the protein,
and it could cause this
thing to change shape.
It could unfold, or it might
unfold in such a way as to
open a channel down
the center here.
And so in response to a change
in pH here, we open up a
channel, which means this is
acting as a chemical gate.
This is how things
are animated!
It responds.
And then once the proton
concentration has been
depleted and you're back to a
more neutral pH, then this
thing changes back to its
old confirmation,
and the gate closes.
It's that simple!
The secondary bonding
explains animation.
That's what's happening.
And there's one other
cool thing.
Look at this.
If they all have the
same head, They're
going to close pack!
It's fantastic.
Everything.
Everything you need to
know, 3.091 here.
All right.
So what is the key
to animation?
The key to animation
is self-assembly.
And why do we have
self-assembly?
Because we have these molecules
with the hydrophilic
head and the hydrophobic tail.
These molecules are called
amphipathic.
OK.
So this has hydrophobic and
hydrophilic components.
So if you take amphipathy, you
end up with self-assembly.
That's the key.
All right, good.
All right.
I think that's all I want
to say about lipids.
That's all you need to know
about lipids, is lipids will
give you cellular structure.
Now we've got a little bit of
time left, and we're going to
talk about nucleic acids.
So what do I want to say
about nucleic acids?
Nucleic acids carry
information.
They carry information that
directs metabolic activity,
including replication.
And something can be animated,
but it doesn't count as a life
form unless it replicates.
That's the characteristic of
life forms. So nucleic acids
carry information that directs
metabolic activity, including
replication.
So these are macromolecules.
Not polymers, but
macromolecules.
We'll take a look in a moment
at their structure.
They're macromolecules, and the
basic structural unit is
called a nucleotide.
And it's got three
building blocks.
Every nucleotide has three
See, what we're doing right
now, is we're really tying
together all of that chemistry
you've been learning the
entire semester.
And it's fun to see it
actually go to use.
So what are the three
building blocks?
Every nucleotide has a sugar.
And we didn't study
carbohydrates, but I'll just
show you the structure
the sugar.
It's got an amine.
You know what that is.
That's the NH something group.
And it's got a phosphate.
So the nucleotide has those
three components,
So let's take a look
at the sugar.
There's really two types of
sugars found in amino acids.
There's the ribose--
and the only reason I'm showing
you this, is so that
you'll understand
the terminology.
There's the deoxyribose.
So if you look here, the sugar
on the left has this five-fold
symmetry, the five-fold ring.
And there's hydroxyls at the
number one position, number
two position, number
three position.
The deoxyribose is missing
the hydroxyl at
the number two position.
That's the difference.
The reason I'm showing you
this, is this is called
deoxyribose, and ultimately
this is the D in DNA.
So you'll be able to at least
hold your own with your course
seven major friends,
if you have any
friends in course seven.
And you can say, I know
what the D is.
It's deoxyribose.
OK.
So then the amines.
The amines we've got, there's
five of these.
And they split for
RNA and DNA.
And they're shown here.
So it's interesting.
There's two of them that are
called purines, because
they've got this
ring structure.
And then the six fold, and
then the five fold.
So these are the purines, and
then the pyrimidines have just
the six fold structure.
There are three of those.
So A, G, C, U, and T.
Those are the five different
amino acids.
And the difference is that in
DNA, you only have A, G, C and
T, whereas in RNA, you
have A, G, C, and U.
This is the chemistry.
If you take 7012, you'll figure
out how all of this
other stuff goes.
And this thing here
is phosphate.
And why is phosphate present?
Because it's acting as the
bridge and a spacer.
So let's take a look
at the structure.
OK.
There's more of the amines
in nucleic acid.
So this is what it looks like.
So you have a backbone that
consists of sugar phosphate,
sugar phosphate, sugar
phosphate, shown here.
So in this case, you've
got the deoxyribose.
So there's the sugar, there's
the five-fold symmetry.
Then the spacer, the phosphate,
then the sugar, and
then the spacer,
the phosphate.
And you can see that the sugars
are acting as hangers
for these amine groups.
And they're called bases,
because in fact they act as
Bronsted bases.
They're proton acceptors, and in
the early days of molecular
biology, people determine the
chemical composition by wet
assay, and these
were determined
to be Bronsted bases.
And so to this day, people refer
to them as base pairs,
et cetera, et cetera, even
though now we know they're
amines, et cetera.
So this is the structure
going up.
And you see, at one end, you've
got the three, and
going up to the five.
The three is, you have the
carboxylic acid end, and at
the other end you have
the amino end.
OK.
So there the structure.
And you have a choice here.
So again, the sugar hanger,
the phosphate spacer, the
sugar hanger, the phosphate
spacer.
And you have a choice of
one of these four.
Any one of these four is what's
found in a DNA strand,
as you go up the strand.
Now, how is information
encoded?
Well, the information
is encoded--
first of all, we have
to recognize what
the structure is.
Know that the structure, turns
out that it forms a double
helix, which is the first
secondary structure, right?
It doesn't have. The primary
structure is this instant A,
C, G, T sequence all along.
And then the secondary structure
is, in order to
maximize hydrogen bonds, this
forms a double helix with a
second chain.
And furthermore, the pairing
is such that A always pairs
with T, because they have two
hydrogen bonding sites between
them, whereas C pairs with G,
because they have three
hydrogen bonding sites
between them.
And furthermore, look
at the spacing here.
This always just stuns me.
If you look down the center
of the strand--
so I've got two strands
of nucleic acid.
The center to center spacing is
1.085 nanometers between A
and T, and it's 1.085 nanometers
to four significant
figures between C and G.
And you might say, well, is it
possible that I could take two
of these hydrogen bond sites and
line them up to two of the
three hydrogen bond sites?
And the answer is no, because
the spacing is wrong.
You can't, these two are far
enough apart that they won't
line up here.
So it's guaranteed that it's
always A to T, C to G.
All right.
So now you see the
double strand.
You have one strand moving up.
You see the pentagon is pointing
up, and here you see
the pentagon is pointing
down, and we have the
base pairs in between.
C pairs to G, and
T pairs to A.
And down here is the basic end,
the acidic end, the basic
end, the acidic end.
And so the secondary structure
is the double helix.
Why?
To maximize hydrogen bonds in
between, and then to keep
maximizing hydrogen bonds.
Hydrogen bonds between
the galleries.
Maximize, maximize, maximize.
So there's what they call the
base pairs, and et cetera, et
cetera, et cetera.
This distance is all prescribed
by the fact that we
have the phosphate present.
OK.
Now where's the information
here?
I said this encodes metabolic
information.
Well, suppose I want to direct
protein synthesis.
I want to put amino acids
in a sequence.
So I have to be able to call.
You know, I'm sitting here as
nature, and I'm saying, I want
to make this protein.
So I need this amino acid, and
then I need this amino acid,
and then maybe that amino acid,
and put them in sequence.
So I need 20 different
words to call 20
different amino acids.
Well clearly, clearly if I have
just A, C, G, and T--
so if I have one-letter
words, it won't work.
Because I need to call out 20.
I need 20 amino acids.
So how am I going
to get to 20?
I don't have 20 of these.
I'm only using, there's
only four of these.
So I say, oh.
I know what to do.
I can use this idea.
The number of words will equal
the number of letters that I
have in my alphabet, raised
to the power, number
of letters per word.
OK?
So if I use this idea,
then I can say--
what if I have two-letter
words?
So in other words, to call out
an amino acid, I have to take
two base pairs in sequence.
That means I'll have--
there's only four letters.
But if I have two letters per
word, that's 16, which is
still less than 20, and that's
no good, because I
can only call 16.
So what does nature do?
What if I had three-letter
words?
Three-letter words, then, is a
64, which is greater than 20,
and that works.
So now I've got, in point
of fact, 61 of these
three-letter words.
So I go down the sequence.
First base pair, second base
pair, third base pair.
That triad represents
one amino acid.
I've got 61 to call out 20, And
I've got three left over.
For what?
Well, let's think about this.
See this?
How do you know to read this,
defined by their properties?
You know to read from
left to right.
You know that there's a space
here between words.
So if I just give you
this strand of
DNA, where do I begin?
Do I take these three, or
do I start counting
from here or here?
So built into this, it tells you
to read either from left
to right, or right to left.
It tells you where to
start, and it tells
you where to stop.
These three-letter words, by
the way, are called codons.
So we've got sixty-one to call
out 20 amino acids, which
means, some amino acids have
more than one name.
There's one of them that has
six different names.
There's six different codons
that can call it
a given amino acid.
For some of them it's only
one, for some it's
two, three, et cetera.
OK.
So that's the information.
Look!
Here it is!
There's the information!
It's all in there.
Just hydrogen bonds like this,
hydrogen bonds like this.
It's all bonding.
So here's the codon.
So somewhere here, see, we take
this, this, and this.
This triad represents one
piece of information.
All right.
So let's go back and look
at some of the history.
Who got us to this point?
This is fresh!
A lot of this happened
in my lifetime.
All right.
So Oswald Avery--
this is before my lifetime.
He was working at the
Rochester Institute.
And he was the first
person-- he was
born in Halifax, actually.
And he worked professionally
here in the United States.
And he was the first person to
recognize that nucleic acids
store and transmit genetic
information.
Up until the 1940s, people
thought nucleic acids--
are you ready for this?--
are too complicated.
Their structure was too
complex to contain
information.
It's precisely the complexity
that gives us the abundance of
information!
The prevailing belief was that
proteins contained the genetic
information.
But people couldn't figure
out how to make it work.
So he was the first to make the
argument that the nucleic
acids have the information.
And then the second giant
is Erwin Chargaff.
Erwin Chargaff worked at
Columbia in New York, and
hospitals in the vicinity.
And he was a painstaking
analytical chemist. He did all
of this work by analytical
chemistry, and he gave us
Chargaff's Rules, 1949.
And he said that in any
biological system, the
concentration of a--
remember, they didn't know
the structure of DNA yet.
I'm going to lead up to how we
get to the structure of DNA.
So we're going back, this is
like a flashback in a movie.
Now we're going back to see
how we got to the double
helix, all right?
People knew that the
concentration of A in any
nucleic acid was equal to
the concentration of T.
They knew that there were sugar
present, they knew there
were amines present,
and they knew there
were phosphates present.
That's all they knew, based
on chemical analysis.
And now he tells us that, of the
amines, concentration of A
always equals concentration of
T, concentration of G always
equals concentration of C.
And then the sum of
concentration A plus G is the
sum of C plus T.
That's Chargaff's rule.
And so here we are,
Homo sapiens.
31, 31, 19, 19, a little bit of
statistical error, et cetera.
But look!
Corn!
Yes!
Corn reproduces using
this same code.
All living organisms on this
planet use the same code.
Which makes sense!
If I eat corn, and I'm going to
get nutrition from it, and
it's going to help me build
cells, and regenerate my body,
and get energy from it, it has
to be made of this same stuff,
otherwise my body can't
recognize it!
Because I'm a biological
machine.
This is not a fireplace
in here, right?
If it's a fireplace, you
can drink something
combustible and boom!
You've got energy.
But we can't derive energy from
something combustible.
We can only derive energy from
something like this.
So, you know, when you think
you're really hot stuff, your
DNA is not that different from
that of an ear of corn.
So a little bit of humility
might be in order.
All right.
And then the last person
we want to talk
about is Rosalind Franklin.
Rosalind Franklin worked at the
King's College in London,
and her specialty was
x-ray diffraction.
And she made painstaking
experiments where she could
take a strand of DNA with a
stainless steel needle and
pull it out of an aqueous
solution, and hold it in a
chamber where the chamber was
humidified so that the DNA
didn't dry out.
And while it was humidified in
this chamber, take an x-ray
diffraction exposure for hours,
because all of the
recording was done by film.
By halide photography,
and you had to have
long exposure time.
This is one of the most famous
images of the 20 century.
This is the image of
the DNA from calf
thymus, the beta structure.
And this is a Laue pattern.
So the symmetry of this pattern
is reflective of the
symmetry in the DNA structure,
which people don't know yet.
And what you see is
five positions.
One, two, three, four, five.
Four is missing.
There's no reflection there.
But it's where you would expect
a position to be.
So it's sort of Bragg-like,
isn't it?
Not all of the lines
are reflecting.
On the basis of this image,
this is what we learned.
We learned, first of all, that
the Laue pattern is indicative
of a double helix.
Based on X pattern.
Remember, they had no computers
in those days!
All they had was a
pencil and paper.
So to do the Fourier transform,
and go back out of
K-space, and discern what
the pattern is--
you know, today it's trivial!
They did this all longhand.
Number two.
On the basis of that pattern,
you learn that it's 3.4
angstroms between nucleotides
along the backbone.
We don't know what
the backbone is!
We just know that there's
sugar, there's
amine, there's phosphate.
There's different ways
of putting this
together to make a chain.
And the third thing that you
learn, because the strong,
clear lines indicate
that the heaviest
elements must lie outboard.
What does that mean?
If you've got a double helix,
based on the first finding,
what's the heaviest element?
Phosphorus.
Because otherwise you've got
carbon, oxygen, nitrogen.
Nitrogen is atomic mass 14.
Phosphorus is atomic mass 30.
So it must be outboard.
Otherwise, if it were inboard,
there would be other elements
farther out, and you wouldn't
get the clear lines.
Because the heavy elements are
the ones that give the
reflection, and if the heavy
elements are obscured by
lighter elements that are
shielding them, you get a
lousy reflections.
Blunted reflections,
blurry reflections.
So all of that comes out
of her findings.
So what happens next?
So there's the 3.4, and 10,
and et cetera, et cetera.
All of that happens based
on the pattern that
I just showed you.
So I'm going to read to you what
happens in those days,
back in the 1950s.
There was intense competition.
You know, Linus Pauling had
proposed a triple helix, and
people in the UK were working
hard on it, and so on.
A lot of competition.
So what happens is that Watson
goes down to King's College in
London, and he meets Rosalind
Franklin in the hallway, and
they get into a big argument.
And she really chews him him
out, and he goes running away.
She was very tough.
And so he goes to Maurice
Wilkins, who was her boss.
And I'm reading, now, from
Freeman Judson's book.
"Wilkins told Watson as they
went down the hall that
Franklin had found that DNA
fibers, when kept wet, yielded
a different x-ray pattern,
suggesting a second structure.
Fourteen months after the King's
colloquium, despite
repeated correspondence and
conversations, visits, meals
together between Wilkins,
Watson, and Crick, the
possibility of a second
structure was news to Watson,
he wrote."
Now, this is quoting
from Watson's own
book, The Double Helix.
'When I asked what the pattern
was like, Maurice went into
the adjacent room to pick up a
print of the new form they
called the beta structure.
The instant I saw the picture,
my mouth fell open, and my
pulse began to raise.
The pattern was unbelievably
simpler than those obtained
previously, the a-form.
Moreover, the black cross of
reflections which dominated
the picture could arise only
from a helical structure.
With the a-form, the argument
for a helix was never
straightforward.
With the b-form, however, mere
inspection of its x-ray
picture gave"--
listen to this-- "several of the
vital helical parameters."
I'm going to come
back to that.
"The picture that Wilkins showed
Watson was Rosalind
Franklin's, without
her approval."
So then Watson goes on the train
back to Cambridge, and
sits down with Crick, and in
no time, they've put the
structure together.
And this is a famous picture.
This is Crick.
This is Watson.
And I don't know if you
can see really well.
These are lab clamps
that they're using.
This is a lab stand.
They're using lab clamps to put
the structure together.
So here's the paper.
The paper as it comes
out, Molecular
Structure of Nucleic Acids.
And this was the first
image of DNA.
And I submit to you that if
the earth were to end in a
giant explosion, and we were to
only send two images in a
spaceship out to let some other
race discover what we're
all about, it would be
this image, and the
image of the atom.
That's all you need.
Because you have the simple
atom, and you've got this, and
everything else is just
detail in between.
So there's the first image.
All right.
"We wish to suggest a structure
for the salt of
deoxyribonucleic acid.
The structure has novel
features which have
considerable biological
interest. The structure for
nucleic acid has already been
proposed by Pauling and Corey.
They kindly made their
manuscript available to us in
advance."
These guys never made their
manuscripts available to Corey
and Pauling.
"Their model consists of three
intertwined chains with the
phosphates near the fiber axis
and the bases on the outside."
See, they got the
positions wrong.
"Without acidic--" da, da,
da, da, da, and so on.
Whatever.
Now here's--
remember, I've quoted
from Watson's book.
"The previously published x-ray
data on deoxyribonucleic
acid are insufficient for
a rigorous test of our
structure."
Really?
"So far as we can tell, it is
roughly compatible with the
experimental data, but it must
be regarded as unproved until
it's been checked against some
more exact results."
Remember, he's writing this
after having seen Rosalind
Franklin's x-ray pattern.
"Some of these are given in the
following communications."
Yeah, the next paper is Rosalind
Franklin's paper.
"We were not aware of the
details of the results
presented there when we devised
our structure,--"
That's a lie.
"--which rests mainly, though
not entirely, on published
experimental data and
stereochemical arguments."
You know what? once I've given
you the data, and you know
what the structure is, you can
give me a very, very strong
stereochemical argument.
But that's hindsight.
If you don't know what the
structure is, you have no idea
what the stereochemical
arguments are, because you can
justify anything.
So this is just absolute lies.
Who are the authors?
Watson and Crick, even though
it's based on data that was
taken from other people.
So here they are.
This is the acknowledgments.
We're indebted to--
blah, blah, blah.
The experimental results in
ideas of Wilkins, Rosalind
Franklin, and their coworkers
at King's College.
And one of us, Jim Watson, he
was the American, and I think
there's an irony here, was aided
by a fellowship from the
National Foundation for
Infantile Paralysis.
And I think there's a joke
there, if you know anything
about Jim Watson.
And now contrast
that with this.
This is the publication
of the human genome.
And look at all the
names here.
Everybody who was involved in
the enterprise was named.
This is not the paper.
This is just the names
of the authors.
Now, to be literate, there's
this one phrase.
Typical British understatement.
Remember, this was about
the structure of DNA.
But there's this passage.
It has not escaped our notice.
This is the litotes.
Understatement, right?
"It has not escaped our notice
that the specific pairing we
have postulated immediately
suggests a possible copying
mechanism for the genetic
material."
That is the understatement
all time.
We've got the structure of DNA,
and parenthetically, I
think this is how you direct
replication in all living
creatures, by the way.
So when this paper
was published.
and they rolled out
the human genome
as a sort of a literary--
what's the word--
allusion, thank you.
The literary allusion was--
there's a passage in this
paper that at one point begins
"It has not escaped our
noticed," da, da, da, da.
So if you're ever with some
Course 7 people, and you want
to really get under their skin,
you know, you could be
at a party or something, and
finally, you say you know,
it's not escaped my notice.
And they know what
you're saying.
It'll make you less popular
then you are now.
So let's fast forward.
This is Stockholm, December
10, 1962,
the Nobel Prize ceremony.
Here is the King of Sweden.
This is Francis Crick.
This is James Watson.
This is Maurice Wilkins.
No Rosalind Franklin.
This is Kendrew, and I'm
drawing a blank.
These two guys were getting the
Nobel Prize in Chemistry
for hemoglobin structure.
This, if you look carefully, is
John Steinbeck, getting the
Nobel Prize in Literature.
Over in Oslo is Linus Pauling,
getting his second Nobel
Prize, but for peace.
So ironically, he's getting
his Nobel Prize.
They're getting the Nobel Prize
not in Chemistry, not in
Physics, but in Medicine.
You know, what's medicine?
I mean it's not really
a science.
But anyway.
Here it is.
It's worthy of a Nobel Prize.
So what really happened here?
What really happened?
Why was there no Rosalind
Franklin?
She was marginalized
as a woman.
She was mistreated
by these men.
It was 1955.
You realize in the 1950s--
and I'm not talking about the
England of Charles Dickens.
I'm talking about the England
after World War II.
Women were not allowed
in the common room.
And the common room
is where everybody
congregates at 4:00 p.m.
to drink coffee and
exchange ideas.
So she couldn't go into the
common room and so on.
And it was just a terrible,
terrible story of misuse, of
information, lack of
attribution, and so on.
If this story were unfolded
today, I guarantee you these
guys would not be getting a
prize, and in fact, the
publication would probably be
rescinded on the grounds of
its fraudulent claims, that
they were unaware of the
previous information.
So after the paper was
published, she was so
brokenhearted that she resigned
her position at
King's College, and took a job
at another college in London.
Her terms of severance included
her signing a
document in which she agreed to
abandon all future work in
biochemistry.
I mean, imagine that you leave
your job, and they tell you
what you cannot do!
I mean, obviously, if you were
privy to intellectual property
and so on, you're bound
by confidentiality.
But no one can tell you, you
can't go to work for somebody!
And so she changed fields, and
made seminal discoveries in
two other fields outside
of the DNA work.
So why isn't she here?
She died of cancer in
1958, very young.
And you can't get the Nobel
Prize posthumously.
So some people are quite
outraged by this story.
But there's a symbolism
here to have Wilkins.
It's basically saying that
you two guys are not
the authors of this.
And so some people say that
Wilkins is standing in for
Rosalind Franklin, and the
Nobel committee at least
acknowledged that.
So what's the message here?
The message here is, I hope
nobody in 3.091 is ever
embroiled in a controversy
like this.
We have to acknowledge
our collaborators.
All of us are here because
somebody helped us.
Don't go away.
You haven't been
dismissed yet.
This is important.
What I'm telling
you is far more
important than that structure.
I'm telling you how to
stay out of jail.
See, here, you know, 50 years
ago, you cheat and steal, you
get a Nobel Prize.
Today you go to jail.
It is a Nobel Prize
in Medicine,
of course, but anyway.
So this is a book, if you're
interested in Rosalind
Franklin's story, it's
fantastic reading.
Real page-turner.
This is James Watson's book.
If you read this, you know,
have your you-know-what
sensors on all the time.
And here's a picture of
Rosalind Franklin
on vacation in France.
And we'll leave with The Twist
by Hank Ballard, who was
another person who
was marginalized,
because he was black!
And so you couldn't listen to
this music, and so there was a
cover made.
The version of The Twist that
you have heard is probably by
Chubby Checker.
This is the original one
by Hank Ballard.
It's gritty.
It's very gritty.
All right.
Treat each other well.
Get out of here.